herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
episode kari antwort ich heute mit
janosch und neuss ist es unsere bachelor
und hat uns gerade jetzt spontan
getroffen hier bei den niagarafällen auf
der grenze zwischen kanada und den usa
dort sind die usa hier ist kanada hat
uns also extra in kanada besucht und
woher kommst du ich komme aus lockwood
in new york der usa und wir fahren
gleich weiter nach new york vorher
machen wir ein kurzes video für euch und
wir beantworten wie immer
zuschauerfragen heute aber live wir
beantworten die fragen von moises los
geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meistens was ist deine erste frage ok
habe zwei frage 1 für dich und die
andere für janisch die letzte frage ist
ich weiß dass du in kanada für ein paar
tage war also was haben die canadiens
über donald trump gesagt gar nichts gar
nichts wirklich wieso sollen sie über ok
es könnte ein thema sein aber wir haben
nicht über trump geredet es ist ja
witzig weil ich fahre nach kanada waren
pro woche und wenn die leute finden die
ich oder wenn die leute merken ja merken
die ich amerikanische oder amerikaner
wenn die ärzte frage die ich immer
fragen ist hast du für donald trump
gewählt ja und das ist sehr sehr komisch
komisch in wirklichkeit es postiert mich
weil in der in der usa wir sprechen
nicht über politischen themen mit mit
leiter das ist eine private sache
das ist witzig weil das habe ich von
vielen amerikanern schon gehört dass
politik viel privater ist als bei uns in
deutschland zum beispiel sprechen wir
gerne über politik und es ist teil
unseres alltags unseres alltäglichen
gespräch aber in den usa das haben mir
viele amerikaner erzählt gerade jetzt in
diesen zeiten wo es mehr spannungen gibt
und noch mehr uneinigkeit versuchen die
leute das sehr privat zu halten oder
reden nicht mal in der familie darüber
und in deutschland ist das überhaupt
nicht so
für uns politik ist wichtig aber es ist
eine private sache ja ich finde das
super interessant aber vielleicht kommt
das auch daher
in deutschland hat man viele parteien
und viele verschiedene meinungen und
viele optionen
deshalb ist es nicht so gefährlich
darüber zu reden nicht so schwarz und
weiß es gibt nicht richtig und falsch
sondern es gibt viele kleine michel wege
ok ja was ist eine zweite frage ist es
also diese frage ja nich warum hast du
nach deutschland warum bist du nach
deutschland gekommen
also in meinem land in polen gab es eine
1 etwas ähnliches an ähnlichen zustand
wie ein bürgerkrieg das militär und die
polizei hat zwei jahre lang das land
regiert und als es vorbei war bekam ich
ein passwort und wenn dann geflohen
und mir war egal wohin hauptsache raus
aus diesem gefängnis unseres land war
wie ein gefängnis und ich landete in
deutschland ich wollte aber nach amerika
da aber meine eltern und großeltern in
dem part gelebt haben weil es früher
noch deutschland war dürfte ich eine
deutsche staatsangehörigkeit bekommen
und deshalb war das für mich sehr
einfach in deutschland zu bleiben und
ich bin in deutschland geblieben
und wenn du in deutschland war die war
die transaktion war war es einfach für
dich oder es war sehr kompliziert und
schwierig und die deutsche kultur zu
kennen zu lernen sich zu integrieren ja
also es war sehr sehr einfach für mich
ich hatte eine sehr gute schule bekommen
ich durfte acht monate lang jeden tag
acht stunden lang deutsch lernen und ich
durfte er dann später mehr aussuchen
welche ausbildung ich machen möchte und
ich lebte in einen sehr hübschen start
in deutschland in münster eine sehr
angenehme sehr liebe sehr grüne
fantastische stadt und das hat das war
sehr einfach sich dank haben wir alle
deine fragen beantwortet weil ich glaube
er hat noch eine gefahr
er sprach von drei fragen ja es gibt ein
ja ich habe eine andere frage
ich weiß dass du verheiratet
die frage ist wie geht s und deutschland
also du willst für verschiedene kulturen
vielleicht ein bisschen einfach ähnlich
aber verschiedenen und wgs und deine
beziehung ja ok mid mid mid die unsere
verschiedenen kulturen mit kulturen
probleme für die beziehung sind ja das
ist eine gute frage gibt es ein problem
zwischen deutschen und polen zwischen
deutschen und polen aber auch zwischen
uns gibt es eine altersunterschied und
der könnte auch unter umständen zu einem
problem werden aber denke und ich unsere
sprache zum beispiel es gibt durchaus
deutsch gelernt und ich spreche englisch
aber ich war im büro geboren und meine
frau basierende usa geboren und wir
haben manchmal missverständnisse wegen
dass sprache
also ich denke sagte wieder als
innovativ
wir haben nicht so viele
missverständnisse war yannis schon
fließend fast perfekt deutsch sprach als
wir uns kennengelernt haben
aber ich bin manchmal ein bisschen
gemein wenn er etwas in deutsch sagt was
witzig klingt weil es ein fehler gibt
dann mache ich witze darüber und das
sollte ich nicht machen ja nicht nur wir
sondern sie spricht dass nach mit diesem
schweren slawischen aktien und danach
sie darüber aber ich liebe das ich mag
das weil für mich
karli hat viele gebiete wo sie nicht
lachen will weil sie ist sehr sehr
feinfühlig und mit mehr kann sie ein
bisschen sich ein bisschen ausleben
dieses politikers unkorrekt ist ein
bisschen und ich verlasse dafür
quatschen okay also du sagen sich bei
mir ein bisschen aus stoppen ich bin so
deutsch und so ernst wenn ich ja nicht
hätte hätte ich gar keinen spaß am leben
haben wir alle seine fragen beantwortet
meistens ja ich denke ich oder er habe
das gemacht wenn ich mehr frage habe
werde ich sie schreiben ok unbedingt und
das sollten wir auch machen wir werden
wenn wir dieses video veröffentlichen
auch bei instagram fragen beantworten
deswegen klickt auf unsere instagram
seite der link ist hier unten und dort
könnt ihr alle fragen stellen die ihr
habt organisch und ich werden sie dann
beantworten heute abend tschüss und bis
bald
danke dass wir dich